hey margo hey david hi hey
david i cannot get enough of polka dot
man and his mommy issues
this is so good it's a thing
it is a thing we all have them to some
degree or another and abners are deep
they're so deep it's so true and then
harley you know she's got some daddy
issues so
you know yeah i think everyone on the
spot has
issues
the prerequisite if you're going to be
on this part of the suicide squad you
got issues
um i know margo you basically shot birds
of prey and the suicide squad back to
back
does a little bit of harley stay with
you
offset when you're playing a character
for so long
she kind of does yeah i i catch myself
doing it like i think like five percent
of her sticks around and
suddenly i'll say something i'll do
something and i'm like look
that was so harley just then i was like
i'm trying to shake it off it's like
yeah she sticks around sometimes and i i
feel a little
i feel a little loopy i love that stuff
and she's gone now i'm not gonna turn
into hell
you cleansed her all right okay most
important question out of everybody on
the suicide squad who do you think
king shark would eat first if given the
chance
okay david well
probably the biggest meal so i
get is that uh boomer maybe is the
biggest
most no no that would be um that would
be
i guess i don't know who's whoever's the
biggest meal wherever he gets the most
bang for his bite i guess so we have to
do a height comparison contest yeah
maybe peacemaker he's pretty much that's
that's
that's yeah i mean john cena it's weird
it's all camera angles and lenses and
like they put stuff on there
he's super thin in real life i mean he's
just there's no muscle
all that is like it's incredible i could
put my hand around his arm like that
i believe you margaret who do you think
he'd eat i agree peacemaker
thank johnson
okay now if there was a suicide squad
buddy cop film who would you want your
character
to team up with margot go who would
harley be awesome with
thank you yeah
i was like i was like that's even a
question morgan
are you kidding me like i'm sorry
but like the people are crying in the
streets for it
already the movie hasn't even come out
yet they're like where is our
sitcom about harley and pokey it's gonna
be amazing they're roomies they live in
yeah the phantom i hear
all the time i wanted to this needs to
happen please
put it out into the universe um i just
got kind of the wrath of the time but
uh margot do you want to know how
harley dies after was revealed in zack
snyder's justice league
i know someone told me that in an
interview i had no idea i was like wait
what
but it was like a quick little like
batman just says it
yeah but you know what there's a lot of
leeway in the comic book so
you know you pick up one comic book
something happens you pick up another
one
all those things have been undone so i
feel like there's a lot of like
freedom in the comic book universe
especially the dc comic
book universe just with how each
director kind of has their own
authorship over the film
the way james gunn does with the suicide
squad it's not
it's it's not a sequel it's not a
prequel it's not a reboot it's just its
own thing
um which is good because a lot of people
die in this movie
and uh um i'd hate to think that they
can't ever have a chance to come back
but
a lot of main characters die i agree
david did you want to say something
oh i just i choose to read it as a
batman tactic
it's like he's very smart and he's
playing mental games with different
people so he's like
oh she died yeah like i don't think that
that's the way i read into the
mythology and i'm an authority on this
stuff i just want to say
i'm really i know i don't know i kind of
agree with you
i agree guys so much fun getting to
interview you congratulations on the
film it was so
twisted and fun thank you thank you